[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello.
Dude, these look great.
-Yeah, we should post that.
-What's up, my dudes?
-What's up, du--
Oh, my God!
-Oh, no!
-What happened?
-Oh, sorry I'm late.
Got boned by the subway.
Damn you, C-train.
Um, how y'all doing?
-No, dude, your face.
Did you get Botox?
-Oh, you guys can tell?
-Yes!
-Yeah, just got a little
touch-up.
-What?
-So this is intentional?
Not an accident?
-Yeah, I figured if we're
going to be on camera
a little more,
might as well look my best.
-Ben, you know I love you.
-Love you, too.
-You look like you drowned.
-I feel like I'm at your wake.
You look embalmed.
-I asked for the Chalamet.
Is that coming through?
-No!
-I like it, man.
I paid top dollar
for this thing.
-How much?
-150 bucks.
-That's not enough.
-Not enough?
-For full-face Botox?
-That sucks.
I wish there was an undo button
for this thing. [ Laughs ]
-Your face isn't even moving
when you laugh, dude.
This is so bad.
-I'm sorry. What did you do?
-Oh, my God.
-What is with your fingers?
-Oh, yeah.
I got some work done myself.
-You got longer fingers?
-Oh, my God.
We are not making this
about my fingers.
-Wait, wait, you extended them?
-You know how many YouTube
comments there were
about how short
they were before.
-Well, now, you look like
the Babadook.
-Wow, Martin.
How about you go shh?
-Don't touch my mouth!
-Stop!
-You look like
"Pan's Labyrinth."
-Do I?
-Do this.
That's Pan.
-Oh, yeah.
Well, yeah, sure. Fine.
But these fingers rock.
I feel more confident.
I play guitar easier.
I can do cool stuff
like "West Side!"
-I got Botox. I look good.
-You know what?
Should I get some work done on
my face?
-No, you don't need it.
-I know.
I'm talking about
my second face.
-Ew! Oh, my God!
-What the hell?
-What is that?
-I know. I know.
He needs a nose job.
-No, what the hell is it?
Does it talk?
-He used to,
but then I think he died.
-Oh!
-Okay, this is so toxic.
Can we all agree that we're
beautiful on the inside?
-I guess so.
-Yeah.
-[ Deep voice ] I agree.
-Who said that?
-It was me.
You guys are beautiful.
[ All screaming ]